I came to this video and playing Grand
Master cortex on crow takes on 2 to 12
with a Bulgarian filakia Bulgaria who is
the sky Darwin coolio Savage from rijeka
Croatia ok check maybe we have
transposed into some line that I
actually know I don't really know why
you three well not be six pack I know I
know a bit about the slide that's
something that I studied her years ago
it's a knot not bad this alternative to
them to the main line where the early c5
with Queen chief is just different here
i can actually defend them the King side
for a while and hope to exploit the
weaknesses unknown on the light squares
so black is intending to play Queen to
d7 co into a for Queen c6 playing on the
queenside yeah this I need to retreat
and quit knight c6 to a five as a good
setup
yeah the Queen needs to go to the seven
anyway at least it's a good square the
problem here is one problem is that the
bishop of course mmm should I cool down
Queen a4 first or just 96 yeah let's go
here first the bishop 1g5 always
prevents long castles this is the only
castle hood that I have left so this is
a bit a bit uncomfortable yeah maybe
he's going for f4 hmm
ok some ticking here
Quincy form or is this this is bad i
also have Queen a five teching c3 it's
not bad actually how does he protected
yeah i forgot about this move ok that's
a taxi to again if he takes h5 it's i
think not the end of the world i get c2
check
yeah have some counter play here the H
porn is hanging and he's not so well
coordinated
my day fantasy for yeah okay it's
probably just good for white yeah it's
good for what still needs to be played
but why does is better him check
I'm not sure about that to be honest
I mean it's not hanging and I have some
ideas night see for one night be three
not be three this okay this is not bad
it's a good square it's not hanging
because each one is service attacked to
take care nite f4 hmm
okay you trying to read it
yeah this is some probably a fairly easy
win for a computer but I'm not sure that
it is so easy for what I do if it is
human I have the apron as well its got
this King side stuff of course but da
porn I'm just pushing it okay if we go
here
now it's not easy to play not at all
bishop see one no I can take a one so
this is valid
forgot about that one so
there's some way to to improve this
position I need to get the rook them and
I probably already plated suboptimal
yeah I'm an idiot I really did
everything that you get this the setup
guarini it wasn't so easy really and now
it probably is easy some way to to get
have you know the Queen deform
he takes Queen deform the text the night
at x f4 eyes got night h5 it's got 9 h 5
okay now it was it was so it was an
interesting idea at least it's not
working that's it it was it was
something the IE probably has even other
moves night h5 is simple and good
protects f4 and yeah he's seeing this ok
let's last try
check
Butchie for maybe the sector still some
there's still something left in the
transition check look a for Andrew k8
check
check check check check check check
check time warning check check
white work is always drinking and the
two rocks yeah I probably missed
something before but of course it was it
was completely busted but have you seen
the open king okay let's round here of
course it's it's it's gone it's just
gone and this was the last ditch try
here but the sun just just keeps
everything together five yeah it here he
just he just needs to do something else
just not maybe he can talk I know I mean
this is a complete mess the computer
move is cool King age for ya this is why
computers I good at chess King h4l this
is wrong it it takes the Queen so um
yeah this is very very strong okay I
took check and it's still so winning of
course but yeah it's it's only plus
three you were just surprising check
check
check ya hear this is exactly the win I
only didn't manage to it to finish it
off here it's the Queen screen check a
stronger jack yeah he needs to go here
check check I got Queenie for this is
the big one didn't see that like this
here Queenie for this is a shy decisive
idea here check can just take the book
yeah okay I needed to I needed to play
very quickly as well this is this is
just check this is just a check a
limited number of checks that he runs
out of out of checks wow what a game I
hope you liked it thanks for watching